[Music]
foreign
you
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
um
hi my name is don jacobs i happen to be
a member here at the table
and i just want to thank you so much uh
for joining us
in our morning edition of uh our church
service
uh so yes this is a one-time event
that's happening
uh today um so thank you so much for
adjusting your schedule so that you
could be here
that's so very important to us um and
just a reminder next week we're going to
be back at our normal time at five
o'clock
so hope to see you back next week at
that time so i've got two announcements
um i want to go over with you all one is
about our small group book club
this is a book that's going to be
meeting that meets monthly it's led by
sarah johns and linda baron
so the september's book selection um is
going to be called
simon versus the honey and sapiens
agenda
by bakey becky um
tally i think i'm saying that last name
correctly
um so the discussion for this will be
actually on saturday september the 26th
at 10 in the morning so location is
going to be determined
so if you're interested uh just be sure
to reach out to sarah
her email address is going to be sarah
at the table tx.org
there is a second group small group
that's called the indian
enneagram group so this is a brand new
group that's going to be
led by joe brock and josh reynolds
now for those of you who are not sure
about the enneagram or anything like
that
when i first heard about this this was
something that i didn't know what it was
either
and i and i thought it was something was
kind of weird um so i kind of
just put myself off on learning anything
about it personally
but once i finally made myself learn a
few things about the enneagram it has
changed how i look not just at myself
but
the other relationships in my life so i
i
strongly encourage you to study
something like this
um and if you can join this group this
is going to be a
six-week study that's going to meet on
monday evenings on september the 21st
and it's going to run all the way to
october 26th now space is limited so if
you're interested make sure that you
reach out to joe
her email address is going to be brock
joe josh
yahoo.com um so as we get ready for
morning worship as i know as you know
this is first thing in the morning
or for some of us it's first thing in
the morning um and i just want to help
you get ready
so make sure for me i have to have
coffee in the morning
to get ready for church i have to be in
a comfortable spot especially when we're
doing home church
to kind of get me physically ready but
to get you mentally ready i do have a
journal entry i want to share with you
all
something i had written a few months
prior before kovid
and everything like that do you remember
live before covet it's kind of hard to
remember
but um but i think this this kind of
applies to me
still um especially in where we are
when it comes to dealing with what we're
dealing with with our social distancing
practices
all right so so many so many times i um
want to have my whole life together
and i never do i want others to think
everything is going well like my
relationships between my kids
my family my friends work in community i
want
all of them to be perfect but they
aren't
and sometimes i feel like i'm the only
person that struggles with these
pressures that i deal with
so guilt shame and fear are trusted
companions
uh throughout my week they tell me lies
about myself
the lies about who god is and lies about
who the other people are in my life
and sometimes i actually believe them
so i carry these lies everywhere i go
so i decide to eventually to take them
to church
i don't go to church to look like a good
christian
to my friends or families and i don't go
to church to peace my guilt
for the sundays that i miss because i do
that from time to time
i don't go to church to earn some
spiritual points with god
so that god is happy with my life but i
do go to church
to quiet those voices of shame and guilt
and fear
being in a place where i can focus on my
relationship
with jesus and engage in meaningful
authentic relationships with people
help me to listen more to god
so i've shared this with you because i
hope that you can be encouraged
by not just this group by not just our
church but also
our small groups especially in our time
that we're in and just again to kind of
get us kind of mentally prepared
for today so i'm going to uh
send us off into a prayer so please pray
with me please
lord this thank you so much for this
opportunity and this time that we're
here together
um thank you for um just
again giving us a space where we can
focus on you
and that we can just be able to connect
um in places that give us meaning and
purpose
i pray that you open up our hearts and
our minds to
our time to get together today speak to
us
and be with us throughout this moment in
christ's name
i pray amen
hey good morning everybody thanks for
joining us in this
uh one time only change of time
so i hope everybody like don said woke
up and got their coffee
and is ready to join us and i hope that
um you find meaning in today
through our gathering uh online
lord i find you
in the seeking lord
i find you in the doubt
and to know you
is to love you and
to know so little else i
need you
oh how i need you
oh how i need
you oh
how i need you
[Music]
lord i find you in the city
is
[Music]
oh how i need you
i see you every day
let my life be for your glory
woven your threads of grace i need
you oh
[Music]
i will find all i need all i need is you
light glorious light i will go where
you shine break the dawn crack the sky
make the way bright before me in your
life
i will find all i need all i need is
[Music]
oh
god thank you for today and thank you
for the chance to gather
with the ones we love i pray that we
find meaning and purpose
in what we hear today
amen well thank you
josh and joe and don so
good morning everyone grace and peace
welcome to the table um i know probably
a number of you might be wondering like
why the time change why the switch
and it's because um two very good
friends
of mine and many people here at the
table
lance westbrook and aaron brown are
getting married
uh this evening and lance in particular
was actually really really
instrumental in some of the why behind
us starting this community the table
um so that's a whole story i won't go
into but um needless to say a lot of
people are connected to lance and so
um i realized pretty quickly a lot like
maybe over half of the folks that helped
put on this service each week were going
to be
unavailable this evening and it's like i
really didn't want to just replay a
previous service or something so
um i've got i've kind of pulled in a few
folks to help us
um get something going uh for this
morning so
uh it's i'm grateful thank you to
everyone who's pitching in and
it's really great to be with all of you
in this new new time
so um let's see we are in
part 11. oh before we jump in y'all
notice
new background no it's uh
maggie and mindy uh my wife and
sister-in-law have built
a new wall new panel wall i think that's
what they call it so
i think it's fancy it's great so um all
right
we are in part 11
of our series this is going to be the
finale
um on the gospel of luke and i hope
you've enjoyed it i hope you've kind of
learned something maybe got a different
angle just a deeper understanding of
christ a different angle on the gospel
and so the title my message um today
is a secular age a secular age and
by the way i was rereading my um notes
like on this this morning and i was like
oh my gosh this is a very ambitious
message i think i
it's possible i might be trying to cover
just too much so
um and there's kind of you know
different kinds of messages
there's like the inspirational uplift
message
um that was kind of like a little bit of
last week uh and then there's like the
practical
you know how do i live my life message
and then there's a message like this
which is
i don't even know what it's a lot it's
just a lot it's a lot of history
i think in ways i'm trying to kind of
reframe how we
um engage our culture and to help us how
we view our culture
and then how we live um so it's it's no
small task so what's that used to say
like in school
like put on your thinking caps um to mix
my metaphors
buckle up here we go uh lord help us so
all right our primary text is gonna be
luke 24
verses 9 through 12. and the context for
this of course it's describing the story
of the resurrection of jesus and people
encountering
um the empty tomb all right verse nine
when they this would be a group of women
came back
from the tomb they told all these things
to the eleven and
to all the others it was mary magdalene
joanna mary the mother of james and the
others with them
who told this to the apostles but
they did not believe the women because
their words
seem to them like nonsense
peter however got up
ran and ran to the tomb bending over he
saw the strips of linen lying by
themselves
and he went away wondering to himself
what had happened so if you were here
for my easter message back in april
then you'll you'll kind of hear similar
things i'm drawing
on these similar ideas and i honestly
don't know why this keeps happening to
me but every time i go to write a
message about the resurrection of christ
i am instantly drawn to
um not simply about what people believe
but the very um parameters
for what people and cultures find
believable
can you hear kind of the difference
there in other words um what is it that
any given culture
considers like within the realm of the
possible or the potentially believable
and the reason i'm kind of bringing this
up um
is because i think as a culture many
folks when it comes to resurrection are
just kind of like
i can't really go there um and
and i think it's because it's kind of
falling outside the realm of the
believable
um what we find even possibly like
acceptable so
um now here's the thing on its surface
you could say that
our era our cultural moment and out of
the bible are very similar
because of course the passage we just
read look luke 24 you have the narrator
saying
they did not believe the women because
their words seem to them like nonsense
and in a similar way for many people
today the resurrection
it's just kind of outside the realm of
the believable you know it's just
i mean the stuff about peace and love
and joy and love your enemies and you're
like that's yes
but this resurrection stuff like oh it's
it's sort of nonsense
um but there's a key difference and
between our culture and that culture
and that difference is what i named a
moment ago the disciples
believed it was nonsense not because
they found the idea of god of
miracles or even the concept of
resurrection itself
nonsense um but because they were
skeptical
that this moment was really the moment
when
god's new world was breaking through
they had i mean because of the
crucifixion they had really lost hope
completely that jesus was
who he said he was god's promised
messiah the deliverer who would save his
people from their sins
um and so they found it nonsense
not because if you ask them do you find
the idea of resurrection nonsense they'd
be like no i mean of course not like i
believe at the end of all things god
will
raise us and we will be judged and you
know etc like they could have rattled
off
they found that idea acceptable again it
was just this moment they were like
i don't think this is not how the story
is supposed to go
so that's why they found it nonsense
whereas in our cultural moment it's
different
uh we are living in what the philosopher
charles taylor
has called a secular age and i want to
name up front i have drawn
very very heavily from both charles
taylor
and a lecture by james k smith
where he's kind of popularizing and
helping explain charles taylor
um i've drawn really heavily from them
both to to kind of
um understand this moment we live in now
i think the best way to
to sum up what charles taylor means by a
secular age he wrote a big old book 900
pages
called a secular age um it's to name
that so a secular age is is um basically
naming that before
about the year 1500 a.d like 500 years
ago
um belief in transcendence this is
something beyond this world you know god
the spiritual the possibility of
miracles resurrection
etc um like that those ideas that was
just a given like it was just a foregone
conclusion i mean everyone was a
believer
pretty much everyone um fast forward
though 500 years
and we've under undergone some really
really massive
shifts um i mean now it's totally
acceptable
to you know not believe in god
especially among younger generations
or even if we do claim you know certain
belief on god religion spirituality
it's it's just it's no longer center
stage
in our lives like it was for previous
generations i mean
and and even today in places that aren't
in the west
um there are places that are like still
very spiritually minded you know that's
just their view of the world
it's a god saturated god saturated
cultures
that no that's just not really um
uh ours and uh i mean like for example
it's not at all strange for even you
know believers to kind of attend church
maybe like once a month or
once a quarter maybe never um
whereas i remember back in the day like
this is even just 30 years ago you could
find
people who would like they would attend
church on vacation
maybe some of you have done that but
like that's just an example of the way
we're increasingly
you know even 50 years ago that was like
oh yeah yeah we need to be in church
every sunday you know but
oh the times they are changing
the words of bob dylan and you know no
one's like
that too i mean admittedly even pastor
brad i'm
on vacation
so the thing is um
and this is something i named in my
easter message you know we've we've now
been in a secular age
long enough that um
even though even the non-believers among
us
have doubts about their unbelief
this is so early i was speaking to the
believers now i'm speaking kind of even
to the unbelievers though
like even they it's we've traveled long
enough into this secular
age that that even they're starting to
have doubts and
in other words it's sort of in a strange
twist they're kind of tempted by
faith uh a really great example
um that that james k smith he names is
um the british novelist julian barnes i
wasn't familiar with barnes but
apparently he's kind of like the poster
child of
british uh secularism if you know
anything about britain
you know 150 years ago everyone was a
christian i mean everyone
never went to church was just you know
in the air just what you did
um but there was a shift right this
secular age just really hit britain
and barnes he was part of that shift so
today he's in his 70s so he's not like
necessarily a young man
um but growing up his parents were kind
of early adopters of this kind of
secular thing and so
you know he never went to church just
hasn't really been he he really was not
formed in any overtly religious way
um and but because of this he's not
like kind of an angry atheist or
something he's
um he's not really in reaction to
religion at all because
because you know it's not like he was
raised in it and now he's reacting
against it he
he just was raised not to believe
uh maybe some of you can kind of relate
to that um but then in his 2008 memoir
he wrote this words i think this just
beautifully captures kind of the secular
age we live in
from even the non-believer perspective
he said this i don't believe in god
but i miss him that fascinating
i don't believe in god but i miss him
which is why to say we live in a secular
age notice i'm not saying
that we live in the age of godless
atheism or we live in the age where
no one's religious anymore no that's
that's not quite it
um instead i want to give you two kind
of descriptions of what it is to live in
a secular age basically a secular age is
when number one
um all beliefs no matter which road
you're going
all beliefs are deeply deeply questioned
and doubted in other words there's no
overarching story or account of reality
that everyone just takes as the default
and this is what this is why when for
example um you meet your new neighbors
right if you did this 100 years 150
years ago
i mean i'm just thinking of the u.s
context and you pretty much knew roughly
what they believed
probably um whereas now
like you cannot assume you know people
are on your page like
when you meet new neighbors um right you
can't assume like oh they probably
believe like me
like no you kind of have to feel it out
you know is this okay are they religious
are they not religious if they are
religious you know what kind of religion
maybe do they follow
uh and this is even more true the
closer to the coasts you get in the
united states
or the closer you get to any city
or the younger the person you're talking
to right the more one of those
uh three things is true um the more kind
of
you know innocence careful you have to
be to not just assume they believe
whatever you believe
uh in other words if you're talking to a
person in their 80s from rural kansas
well you know they're probably raised
christian and at least would call
themselves christian even if
they're not like church-going folks
whereas if you talk to a teen
from los angeles uh like
who knows you know they could believe
any one of like a dozen things
um so everyone is in these very
different places
um which means everyone has the
experience
um of having their own beliefs kind of
questioned
simply i mean at the very least just
because people around them don't believe
the same and so you're like
oh who's right maybe i'm wrong you know
we kind of have this this experience
uh in fact i'd say kind of a deep
awareness of this
is what's become popular to call
deconstruction
deconstruction is basically where you
have like you know a whole bunch of
default ideas a whole
story about the world um it's often kind
of a christian framework
but whether through friendships or
you know going to school or reading
books or listening to podcasts or you
know whatever but but you kind of have
those beliefs those
assumptions about this is how the world
works this is the story to believe
deeply questioned and interrogated
and suddenly you're left um
in a place of just of reeling you know
like well
what even is true anymore and notice
again though
this is this is the case for everyone so
if you're a believer
well then you're tempted by unbelief and
if
you're raised and not like a
non-believer well then like julian
barnes
you're kind of haunted by the idea of
god
you know haunted by the question what if
christ's resurrection really is
true so so that's the first
thing to live in a secular age is to
have this experience
of having whatever you believe really
interrogated
questioned all right hope i'm not losing
you second this is going somewhere
second to live in a secular age means
that we emphasize imminence
over transcendence let me explain those
strange words
eminence is about this world
the the material the physical
um you know stuff you can touch and
taste and see
so that's imminence transcendence is
really talking about um existence or
experience
beyond the normal um or the physical
level so transcendence
is about it's about god you know it's
about the supernatural the spiritual
um so every time you pray every time you
uh we walk in the woods and and
feel as though it's it's almost pointing
to
more uh every time you read the
scriptures
and the words just jump off the page
it's like
something speaking to you from out there
you know that that experience something
beyond what you can see in taste and
touch
that's transcendence so what this point
is naming
is that in a secular age even for very
religious people
our imaginations are increasingly
oriented towards the imminent
you might even say that that even our
religious practices
are losing a sense of transcendence that
now it's about
much more imminent things and by the way
this isn't
like totally bad uh i mean for one thing
god became
flesh right god cares about the material
world god
cares about um like our our social and
political realities and
how we all treat each other and i mean
even the lord's prayer
is that god's kingdom would come god's
will would be done
where on earth as it is in heaven all
right what's that prayer saying
that may the transcendent
kiss may it come among us in imminent
ways right that's so
just be clear that's great but notice in
this secular
age it's very easy even as religious
people
to so emphasize the imminent
that we begin to lose touch with the
transcendent so for example imagine a
church
um that you know gathers in small groups
and you know cares for one another's
like emotional
or relational emotional needs um
a church that brings meals to like the
sick
and um speaks up about political
injustice that volunteers and donates
you know to the local food pantry um a
church where the pastor texts people
once a week to like check in
i'm sure it's hard to imagine this kind
of church but stretch your imagination
so imagine that a church
but but over time what if they
kind of so emphasized all those things
um but they stopped praying
because you know who even knows how all
that works uh and then imagine like
just kind of stopped worshiping and
slowly stopped really speaking
about god at all and instead
became totally imminent
um and and i think i'm not saying that's
kind of what we've done at the table i'm
saying as
in living in a secular age that is no
doubt
what we are constantly tempted towards
um but what i'm naming tonight is is is
really that that is that's kind of a
hallmark of a secular age and what it
misses
this is the key is that this we cannot
forget this
that it's the transcendent that
orients us that guides us
towards beauty love truth goodness
in our imminent day-to-day
world if you don't hear anything else i
said because if you're wondering like
where are you going with this why does
this even matter like just supposed to
love
people you know well this is why because
it's the transcendent that orients us
towards beauty love truth goodness in
our imminent day-to-day
world this is um the christian
theologian honzers von balthazar
man with the craziest name but i quote
him often he um he put it this way
he said whoever begins to sneer at the
idea of beauty
in other words at the very concept of
the beautiful he said that eventually
they will no longer pray and soon
will no longer be able to love
can you kind of hear how he's connecting
these idea these ideas
in other words in his name they hang
together it's the transcendent it's the
beauty of christ
the idea that that he is
ultimate reality itself and in my job as
a christian is to orient and
center my imminent day-to-day life on
the transcendent right in other words to
for heaven to kiss earth like in
my life but what happens if i
lose the transcendent what happens
i eventually i'm losing my north star
i'm losing my compass my orientation for
my
imminent day to day life this is why
as a pastor i care really deeply um
about
this uh and sometimes this actually can
i think really happen not just in one
person's life like it's not like
we're kind of living in a way and we
have certain ideas and ways of viewing
god and then we maybe lose that or start
drifting from that and then our you know
personal lives just fall apart and we
just start living in antichrist ways or
something you know more often what
happens
um this happens kind of generationally
it's kind of gradual so for example
let's say mom and dad
um you know kind of we go through a
season of like
of kind of deconstructing the faith and
maybe that leads us to a place where we
kind of stop
orienting our lives on the transcendent
because it's just a big question mark
for us
you know it's like yeah so um
but what do we do in our imminent lives
right our day-to-day lives
well we continue to live out the values
of the christian faith
but what happens but they're kids
right who maybe never learn to pray
who never learned that god is love who
who never
learn the stories of christ that would
lead them
to assume an insane
idea like right which we just start
taking for granted
something like this that everyone
regardless of
wealth or status or power are the
beloved of god
and not only are they the beloved of god
they are worthy to be
treated with dignity and respect and be
fully included in churches and families
in community society
that by the way is a truly beautiful and
completely
insane idea that makes no sense
from an imminent materialist naturalist
way of viewing the world
right it's it's a it's it is rooted in
or it's it's
relying on something transcendent right
to actually make claim like that
so mom and dad continue to live and vote
you know as though that's
true but the kids right maybe pick up a
little bit of it
but for sure by the time you get the
grandkids and the great grandkids in
this trajectory you can see that they're
losing the transcendent
and thus eventually um lose that way of
being
in the world all right so those are kind
of two descriptions
of what is happening in our secular
age so number one all beliefs are deeply
questioned and doubted number two
we emphasize imminence over
transcendence
now this thought causes um in certain
circles of christendom like a lot of
anxiety
and people start kind of railing against
this godless secular age you know
and the moaning like why don't people
come to church anymore you know
whatever um i'm not gonna say that like
that's not how i see this
i actually think that this is an amazing
moment for us to be the church
because i mean you might say like never
has our work
been more vital like we are the people
who are saying that the transcendent
that god
spirit christ beauty truth like these
things matter
and so bowing our heads in prayer each
day
is every bit as important as the causes
we advocate for
or the places we volunteer um and i'm
what i'm kind of naming is that all
those things hang
together right for example you don't go
volunteer helping
those jesus called the least of these
if if you start kind of if you start
leaving behind the story
of christ that made that make sense in
the first place or even if
you might do it as an individual as i
named earlier your kids probably won't
because they'll just be like
i don't get it right um so they hang
together okay so what does this mean for
us i want to give you two things
and they kind of correspond to each of
my two previous points
all right so first we the church have to
stop
demonizing doubt this was a point james
k smith um made in his lecture where he
named
that the church reacting to this secular
age has at times gotten
um very very defensive um we have shamed
people
for their lack of faith we have shamed
them for having a secular mindset
instead of realizing that it's just
simply a byproduct of the culture
we live in right today we are
all doubting thomas's
all of us uh but instead of having that
disqualify us
what i'm kind of encouraging us to do is
let's choose to be honest
in the vulnerable about that fact with
one another like instead of having to
hide that
like oh i'm not sure you know like let's
create a christian community
where that is not demonized and
um i love how smith put it he said let's
let's believe
two and through one another in other
words
um there are days where my faith is sky
high and so some of you rely on me
and then there are days where your faith
is sky high
and i'm going to have to rely on you
but together what are we doing together
we are
trusting that christ has us and will
lead
us forward so let's become that kind of
a place
all right that kind of a church that's
the first point we have to stop
demonizing
doubt second we need to re-center
on the transcendent uh i'm not talking
here about becoming so heavenly minded
we are no earthly good um honestly in a
secular age
that's not our main problem instead i
think we are becoming so earthly minded
that um like we're no earthly good
in other words if we are as caught up in
anxiety fear
um if we're in as much despair if we
have
started to cynically sneer
at truth and beauty if we've stopped
praying
your kingdom come your will be done on
earth
if our spirituality is just kind of an
add-on you know church is just that's
nice to have
if we shrug our shoulders at
transcendence
then our danger is that either we
or at the very least the generations
watching and listening to
us will become no earthly
good um
that that um i
don't want that to be the inheritance we
give
future generations um i don't
want them to learn from us
like to lose the story to lose the plot
in such a way that
even if we maybe keep on going like
maybe they eventually sneer at beauty
and no longer um pray and then are no
longer able
to love um
yeah that's that's my heart so
that asks that kind of begs the question
i'll close with this like how on earth
do we re-center on the transcendent
how do we do that and honestly it's the
stuff we talk about here
you know nearly every week um
pray you know read the scriptures
read a book on christian spirituality
sit in silence journal take time to
create beautiful things
paint again write poetry again
take time to wonder look up at the stars
and be amazed at who
god is i think what i'm naming is we
must
re-enchant our lives
if a secular age disenchants the world
drains it of its magic then as
christians it's our job to re-enchant
our own lives in the world to re-center
on
the transcendent and then maybe just
maybe
when we hear of the resurrection of
christ
instead of thinking well that's just a
little too much
instead of like the disciples saying
well that sounds like nonsense
um maybe we can actually believe again
trust again maybe then we can be like
peter
who goes to the empty tomb and begins to
think
to himself might this wonderful thing
be true all right
uh by the way if you're interested in
charles taylor or smith's books um i'd
recommend
i'd actually actually recommend james k
smith's book how not to be secular
um basically he takes charles taylor's
massive book
and kind of like puts it into a smaller
more condensed easily digestible
thing so if you're really brave you can
go for taylor's 900 pager
good luck um but some discount is a lot
easier so i think sarah's going to go
ahead and link to those in our comments
below
all right let me pray for you lord jesus
um
i thank you for this this little outpost
of the kingdom
and i asked god that in the midst of a
secular age
where it seems like a lot of folks are
losing the plot
may we may we continue to trust
may we continue to have faith may we
continue to
believe and live into your story
god the story that makes sense of our
world and
in that i believe is really the hope of
the world christ you
are the hope of the world may we be
faithful to that message
the beautiful name of christ i pray amen
hey guys
um we just thought it would be a good
practice to end the service with a song
this is called may we never lose our
wonder
[Music]
mindy had suggested it and
as you just listen along or sing along
or wherever you
are i just want to invite you
just to let it be a prayer
[Music]
let it be a time where we practice
opening ourselves up
[Music]
to more than what we can give ourselves
and to allow god to move and do things
through us that we wouldn't expect
things in us
that we don't think we deserve
let's let this be a time where
we give full permission we release some
of our
maybe our logic the
the part of us that wants to be in
control of everything and understand
everything
i'm one of those people so
i just invite you in to enter in this
space um
i think for me personally that is one of
my favorite parts of worship that's why
i stayed so engaged with it throughout
my life
it's been the thing that keeps opening
and
opening me up and keeps allowing me
to let go of that control
and to reach beyond into something more
beautiful
[Music]
maybe
i wonder
[Music]
let me be just
cause you are
you are beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
you are beautiful
fascinate us
[Music]
you are
you are beautiful
may we never lose
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you fascinated us
with your love
you fascinate us
you're fascinated
you're fascinated us
with your love
[Music]
make me be just like a child
thank you
thank you so much for that maggie um i
just want to thank you so much
for all of you this morning who joined
us
at this new time again just a reminder
that next week we'll be
meeting at a regular time at five
o'clock if you're interested in need
of prayer and support this time don't
forget to
you can reach out to the table on
facebook and just message
us we'll have one of the leaders kind of
reach out
and just follow up with you and then all
of these who support the table
financially just want to say thank you
and your gift just kind of gives us the
ability to support
organizations such as five loaves pantry
that's here in taxi
and those of you who would like to
support us you can go to the website
at thetabletx.com and just select
giving at the top of the page uh also
two other
just a reminder what i mentioned at the
beginning of the service if you would
just remember there are two
book clubs that are coming up uh one
with sarah johnson
glenda bayern simon versus the home and
sapiens agenda
and then the enneagram group with joe
brock and josh reynolds that's also
going to be meeting both
later on in this month there's details
that are in the notes below
and then just let me send you out into
the week with this one
blessing this is from hebrews 13
20 through 21 now may the god of peace
who brought the blood of the eternal
covenant
brought back the dead of the of the lord
jesus
uh through our shepherds peace
equip you with everything that is good
to do his will
and he may work within us what is
pleasing to him
through jesus christ who him be
the glory forever and ever amen
see you next time
you